Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see Listen this
weekend.
Since it was somewhat of a horror story, I
thought it would be fun to talk about favorite
Scary episodes.
Horror is kind of subjective, but I feel like
there are at least a few episodes everyone
can agree on being really scary.
Imagine what Doctor Who would have looked
like had Christopher Lee become one of the
Doctors in the early years.
It would have been the stuff of nightmares.
And quick reminder, this week’s giveaway
is still running.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
I’ll pick a winner in my Q&A tomorrow.
So Top 5 Scary Episodes, Number 5 - Family
Of Blood
Shout out to Harry Lloyd for being such an
amazing creeper.
There’s something about Doctor Who period
episodes that makes them feel scarier.
Maybe because everything looks less familiar.
The monsters from Listen this week remind
me a little of the scarecrow monsters in that
they are relatively features and they don’t
speak.
I definitely think it’s scarier when Monsters
don’t say anything.
One of my favorite props in the episode is
the red balloon Sister Mine carries around.
The episode is also really notable for it’s
use of the Doctor’s Time Lord fob watch.
They take his essence, completely neutralizing
him.
And after it’s all over, the Doctor ends
up looking like the monster.
Here were the punishments he handed out to
the Family of Blood.
Sister Mine was forever trapped in the mirror.
Mother would be forever falling into a star,
Father forever wrapped in chains and Brother
forever a scarecrow in the field.
All because they wanted to live forever.
It’s like the Doctor is a Jinn and he grants
them their wishes but in a really twisted
effed up way.
Number 4 - Brain of Morbius
This is a fourth Doctor Story involving a
battle with renegade Time Lord Morbius.
I think of it as being a twist on the classic
Frankenstein story wherein the Monster eventually
turns on his master.
The classic episodes in general used a lot
of creepy organ and synthesizer music, which
i feel help put you on edge.
For younger people, think of the soundtracks
like old X-Files episodes.
Where it’s like really creepy tonal music.
Some interesting behind the scenes facts.
This is one of the few stories where a gunshot
is heard and blood is seen pouring from a
wound.
There was a reference to the Doctor not carrying
a gun in Listen this week.
The Doctor Frankenstein of the episode is
Doctor Solon, who takes the hand of his servant
Condo, who already kind of looks scary.
And sews it on to Morbius.
When the servant realizes what’s happened
and that Solon replaced his taken hand with
a hook, he shoots condo in the chest a bunch
of times.
Thus the blood.
Much more violent than I can ever remember
modern who being.
Number 3 - Caves of Androzani
This was the Fifth Doctor’s final story.
The villain Jek had this nightmare-inducing
costume and makeup so not only did he look
scary in a post-Star Wars Burned Face Darth
Vader way, but he was utterly insane.
Him creeping on Peri just makes you shiver.
It’s hard to tell if he wants to be with
her or if he wants to eat her for dinner.
It’s like a Buffalo Bill Silence of the
Lambs thing where he feels like a serial killer.
So you can’t apply normal logic to his actions.
To be fair Jek is a villain of circumstance.
So you do feel a little bit of sympathy for
him.
But the who story is one of the darkest regenerations
ever.
That would make a list.
Rank the doctor’s regenerations from Happiest
to Darkest.
It feels like all the modern who regenerations
have been hopeful positive moments.
So Classic Who would just dominate.
Number 2 - Empty Child
I feel like a lot of the tumblr reaction gif
sets use Empty Child gas mask pics just for
the shock value.
The tone of the episode works really well
with the intensity of
the 9th Doctor.
And there was this really cool blending of
a futuristic technovirus with World War 2
set decoration.
I do a lot of Walking Dead videos and Robert
Kirman tells amazing Zombie Stories, but I
feel like Doctor Who’s techno Zombies were
a good twist on the genre.
Ever since George Romero created the genre
with Dawn of the Dead, almost everything has
been a riff on his zombies.
So I always give extra points to stories like
Empty Child that can tell a unique zombie
story.
And the end when the Doctor puts on the gas
mask and repeats the “Are you my mummy”
line.
It feels like the mean type of joke they’d
give to Capaldi.
Although his dark sense of humor is a little
less insane than the 9th Doctors.
There’s something about the 9th Doctor that
made him feel like the craziest of all the
new who doctors.
He was fresh from the war, so he was just
starting to deal with what he’d done.
Like he was still in shock, so he had a much
harder time approximating normal human social
behavior.
And my Number 1 Scary Doctor Who Episode - Blink
Weeping Angels, hands down my own personal
favorite scary monster.
How do you avoid something when your body
forces you to Blink?
It’s almost impossible.
And a lot of times, I feel like the Doctor
and his companions have only escaped the angels
because they’ve been in a group of people
and the Angels nab the red shirts.
I feel like a lot of the brilliance of the
episode comes from the macguffin, the VHS
tapes that the Doctor uses to communicate
and the execution of the angels themselves.
Part of the fun is that the angels don’t
talk, unless you count Angel bob, and they
don’t move when either the characters or
we the audience are looking at them.
For instance, usually when the angels move
on camera, it’s while the camera isn’t
on them.
Or when a video feed a character in the episode
is watching cuts out.
The teeth and claws too.
Whenever I watch supernatural now and see
the human angels like castiel walking around,
I still think of their actual appearance as
being more like the weeping angels.
I don’t expect them back in Series 8, just
because they were used during the christmas
special and all over Matt Smith’s run.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what your favorite scary episode
of Doctor Who is, it can be modern or classic
who.
Like I said, the giveaway for this week is
still open until I post my Q&A on sunday.
I’m sure everyone still has a bunch of questions
about the big twist at the end.
Just in case people haven’t seen it use
spoiler tags if you want to comment on it.
Right now click here to get that Q&A and click
here for my episode 4 review from today.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!